-♪ It's a cold, cold day
and I'm getting the chills ♪
♪ Want to make them go away?
I need something for reals ♪
♪ Whether I'm in my house
or out on the street ♪
♪ I want a hat right now
that can bring me the heat ♪
♪ It's a teenie weenie
beanie ♪
♪ It don't cover your ears,
'cause you still need to hears ♪
♪ it's a teenie weenie
beanie ♪
-♪ Have a bad hair day,
but I don't have the time ♪
♪ Need to make it go away
at the drop of a dime ♪
♪ I can't smooth it out ♪
♪ Looks like I rolled
out of bed ♪
♪ I want a hat right now,
I can put on my head ♪
♪ It's a teenie weenie
beanie ♪
♪ If you don't got a comb,
just put this on your dome ♪
♪ It's a teenie weenie
beanie ♪
♪ Wear a teenie weenie
♪ When I drink a dry martini ♪
♪ Yum ♪
-♪ Wear a teenie weenie
beanie ♪
♪ While I eat
some fettuccine ♪
♪ Whoop, whoop, whoop,
whoop, whoop, yum ♪
-♪ Wear a teenie weenie beanie
while I play a tambourine ♪
♪ Fun ♪
-♪ You know what I'd wish for
if I had a genie? ♪
-♪ No, what? ♪
♪ A teeny weenie beanie ♪
-Michael Douglas is in this film
with you,
the legendary actor
Michael Douglas,
who plays Hank Pym.
So he created
the Ant-Man suit.
And you're doing a scene
opposite Michael Douglas,
and this is a true story.
Please tell me the story
because it's very funny.
-It was his last day
of shooting.
-How is he, by the way?
-He's the coolest.
I mean, he's great.
He's a legend.
And I, you know,
as great as he is,
I could never,
ever shake the fact
that I was working
with Michael Douglas.
You know, it's just -- it's
intimidating and he's so nice.
But I didn't want him to think
that I couldn't be myself.
And I thought, "I'm really going
to try and, you know,
be buddy buddy with the guy,"
and it was his last day.
I thought, "Alright, it's on.
We're doing a close up."
And I thought, "You know
what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna -- I'm gonna
'Basic Instinct' him."
And -- and when he's speaking,
I'm going to sit --
I'm sitting
in a chair across from him
and I'm going to,
you know, just the classic...
Do that.
So, no, I didn't tell him.
I didn't tell anybody.
And I got up to this
and they're getting ready
and I'm wearing a t-shirt
and jeans.
So I, you know,
I unzip my pants, and I...
I get it, you know,
in and out, over and out and...
[ Laughter ]
I'm like,
"This is gonna be great."
-Yeah.
-And so I had
to pull my shirt down
so it wasn't exposed,
you know.
And then and then I figure
I'm gonna sit down and then --
And then when the scene starts,
I'm gonna lift my shirt up
and I'll just be there
like this.
And the one thing that
I didn't take into account
is that
when I sat down that, like,
the waistband of my boxers
was gonna
just kind of smoosh everything,
like push it up and back in.
-Uh-huh.
-So I knew it.
And so you couldn't
see anything.
So I was pulling my shirt down,
trying to get it out.
[ Laughter ]
And he's doing his lines,
not giving you nothing.
Just really a total pro.
-Yeah.
What is he seeing?
I'm really trying.
I'm like -- I should have
just stopped, but I didn't.
And so I'm like...
And it looked like I was
basically pleasuring myself
to Michael Douglas
giving a monologue
because --
And I'm covering it.
And then he's just --
And then he just stopped
and he just looked at me
and said,
"What are you,
A [bleep] pervert?"
No -- No smiles. No.
And I was like,
"Oh, I'm so sorry.
I was I was trying
to 'Basic Instinct' you."
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm just a big,
really big fan of yours."
"I thought it'd be --
I thought it'd be great."
[ "You Spin Me Round
(Like a Record)" playing ]
♪♪
-♪ If I ♪
♪ I get to know your name ♪
♪ Well, if I ♪
♪ Could trace your
private number, baby ♪
♪ All I know is that to me ♪
♪ You look like
you're lots of fun ♪
♪ Open up your lovin' arms ♪
♪ I want some, want some ♪
♪ I set my sights on you ♪
-♪ And no one else will do ♪
-♪ And I ♪
♪ I got to have my way now,
baby ♪
♪ All I know is that to me ♪
♪ You look like
you're having fun ♪
♪ Open up your lovin' arms ♪
♪ Watch out, here I come ♪
-♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
♪♪
-♪ I, I, I, I ♪
♪ I got to be
your friend now, baby ♪
♪ And I ♪
♪ Would like to move in
just a little bit closer ♪
♪ Just a little bit closer ♪
♪ All I know is that to me ♪
♪ You look like
you're lots of fun ♪
♪ Open up your lovin' arms ♪
♪ Watch out, here I come ♪
-♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
-♪ I want your lo-o-o-o-ve ♪
♪ I want your lo-o-o-o-o-ve ♪
♪ All I know is that to me ♪
♪ You look like
you're lots of fun ♪
♪ Open up your lovin' arms ♪
♪ Watch out, here I come ♪
-♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
-♪ I want your lo-o-o-o-ve ♪
-♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
-♪ I want your lo-o-o-o-o-ve ♪
-♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
-♪ I need your love ♪
-♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
-♪ I need your love ♪
-♪ You spin me
right round, baby ♪
♪ Right round ♪
♪ Like a record, baby ♪
♪ Right round, round, round ♪
-I want to thank you for
for being in that group with me.
[ Laughter ]
In the '80s.
-We did -- We did --
I know we introduced --
when we introduced that clip,
there was a lot of bad blood
from the memories.
We had some good times.
-We had some great times.
We're actually friends.
I apologize.
That intro is a little hot.
-Yeah. Yeah.
That was a little hot.
-I will say, though, man,
you were here all day
yesterday doing that.
And it was --
It was disturbing.
-It took a while.
It took long.
Very disturbing.
It took a while to --
I didn't realize, like, he's
hard to sing -- Pete Burns --
to get it -- To get his --
Oh, people don't realize
that it is us singing
on that song.
-We've done --
Yeah, we've done three --
three videos now?
-Yeah, we did Styx.
-Styx and Go West.
-Go West,
"King of Wishful Thinking."
-And those videos are fairly
straightforward vocally,
you know, you can --
But he's got
such a strange vibrato.
I think it took a couple
of hours of, like --
-With the "Baby"?
♪ Baby ♪ That one?
-Yeah. And with ♪ And I ♪
You have to, like, ♪ I, I ♪
-♪ I got your number, baby ♪
-Oh, God.
The crew -- All day, everyone
was walking around, "Baby ♪
And everyone --
Everyone was sick --
Couldn't get it
out of our heads.
-What also was great
is that you were --
You were dressed like that.
I had the long, red hair
and I'm doing my rehearsal
for the show
we were doing yesterday.
And Wu-Tang Clan
is in the hallway.
-Yeah. And I was so --
I was so excited.
I wanted to meet
Wu-Tang Clan so badly,
but I wouldn't leave the room.
I was like, "I'm not --
I can't --
I don't want to meet
Wu-Tang Clan like this."
Yeah, I FaceTimed my kids
when we were filming that,
and [laughs]
I traumatized them.
[ Laughter ]
My son immediately said,
he goes,
"Oh, my God, you look like
you're a real housewife
of Atlanta."
[ Laughter ]
And then he said,
"No. Orange County."
-Oh, yeah.
He corrected himself. Yeah.
Thank you
for working so hard on that.
And someone is going
to split screen that online
and see it is shot for shot,
the same video.
I just love it.
Thanks to our director
and our editor and Paul Rudd.
-Those guys are amazing.
And the crew was awesome.
-And the crew.
Everything -- wardrobe...
Cheers.
Oh, my God. You did it?
How do you do --
Paul, how do you do that?
Paul, don't --
Sorry about that.
I didn't know that --
No, no.
Will, that's poisonous.
That really is.
They are poisonous.
They probably are poisonous.
-There's something --
There's something wrong
with this apple.
-Thank you.
-That's not an apple.
-Welcome.
I will say, Will,
I expected you a couple of weeks
ago on our show
and you didn't show,
to be honest.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I never got the word.
My secretary never told me.
-Franz?
-No. Lil Wayne.
-Yeah. Not the rapper.
-Not the rapper.
-No.
-He's a 320-pound guy
we call Lil Wayne...
-I get it.
-...as, like, a just --
Yeah, it's funny.
Yeah.
-His name is Wayne.
Call him Lil Wayne.
-Yeah.
-No, Lil Wayne
never gave me the --
I feel --
And that's why we're here.
I feel mortified.
-Thank you for both sacrificing
and being here because --
Yeah, because you weren't here.
Ryan Reynolds actually stepped
in to do the interview.
-So nice of him.
-Good dude.
Some -- some would say
Ryan Reynolds is a sexy man.
-Yeah!
-But I would say...
-Yep. I agree.
-...that he is not...
-Yes.
-...the sexiest man alive!
Boom!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You are -- You are --
Paul, I think you're --
Honestly --
-Oh, don't believe
everything you read.
-[ Laughs ]
I will say this when
we announced it on our show...
-Yeah, go ahead.
-..the audience went nuts
because everyone loves
Paul Rudd.
-I know.
-Including us.
We love you.
-And I'm totally cool with it
because I turned it down.
-This is awkward.
-I go, "Paul, I can't do it.
But something's coming
your way."
-So I kind of Ryan Reynolds in
and took it over
and got the title.
I was showing up for Will.
-All you really good-looking
actors just do that for Will.
So he bails on stuff and then...
-I bail all the time.
-It's 'cause we love him.
-Yeah.
I've never met him.
-Me?
-Yeah.
-That's right.
-It's a pleasure.
-You guys -- You guys --
You guys would so
like each other.
I can't believe it's been this
long and you've never even met.
-I'm a big.
-I mean, I'd love to sit down
and talk with you sometime.
-You have been everywhere
doing press
for "Avengers: End Game."
You must be exhausted.
-It's -- It's pretty tiring.
Yeah.
The last few weeks,
I've been to a lot of places.
Started off going to Hong Kong.
Was in Hong Kong,
and then I flew to New York
and then L.A.
And then L.A. to London
and then London back to New York
and then Shanghai
and all within a few weeks.
I've racked up a lot
of frequent flier miles,
but that's the nature
of the beast.
-Do you like flying?
How is the flight to Hong Kong?
-It's long. It's a long one.
-It's a long one?
-But I don't mind it.
I've done it twice.
I've been to Hong Kong twice.
The first time I did it,
I fainted.
I actually fainted.
I had two bowls of soup.
And then I went to the bathroom.
And as I was -- I was getting
ready to go to the bathroom.
And I started feeling
really dizzy.
And I remember there's a handle
and I went to reach for it.
I was like, "Whoa."
And then I just blacked out.
And the next thing I knew,
there was somebody
banging on the door
and my right arm was completely
submerged in the toilet.
[ Audience groans ]
And my left hand
was around my penis.
[ Laughter ]
-Which is odd because normally
you hold your penis
with your right hand.
-I know. Yeah.
-Your left hand's
normally in the toilet.
-That's exactly right.
I had to switch
with the handle.
-Oh, that's what it was.
-But that's how I found out
that I am allergic to MSG.
-No way.
So you really just fainted?
Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah.
-Well, wow. That's amazing.
I'm happy that you're here.
I mean, it's amazing
that you didn't get hurt.
-Amazing that I survived.
-No, exactly. Yeah.
Good luck, man.
Okay. I'm drinking, right?
-Okay, Jimmy,
you will drink this drink.
-Okay. Come on.
Something good.
-[ Laughing ]
Look, look.
-No. Come on.
-Oh!
Peppermint schnapps.
-Not bad. Could be worse.
-That's alright.
-Peppermint schnapps.
Oh, sorry, Drinko.
-Oh, that's alright.
Drink away.
I hope it's schnapps.
-Ohh.
Paul, come down, please.
[ Groaning ]
-Minty fresh.
Alright, Drinko.
I head up there?
-You head up there
and drop your drink.
Drop your disc.
Put your disc in me.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh.
Don't touch that.
Keep both hands where I can --
-Don't touch this?
-Oy!
Got my Christmas goose early.
That's a spangly disc
you've got.
-Alright.
-Drop it.
-I am, Ready, Paul?
-Yep.
-Oy. La la la la la la
la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la.
Gravy!
-Gravy?
-Gravy.
[ Laughter ]
-Paul...
...you have to drink gravy.
-Oh. Ew.
♪♪
-Ew.
-Cold gravy.
-Sorry. Sorry to make you
do that.
Now, Paul --
-Just show them that it really
was gravy in there.
It's so gross.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Delicious.
At least you hope it's gravy.
Now, both of you fellows
are going to mount me
at the same time.
-Alright, Drinko, calm down.
-Go easy, boy.
-Alright, here we go.
I know you have the premiere.
-Assume your positions
and drop your discs in to me.
-Where'd you get them?
-Oh.
-Do you both have your discs?
-Alright.
-Put your discs
against the Drinko board.
-Sorry.
-It's good.
-So what is it?
On the count of three?
-On the count of three,
you both drop your disc.
Whichever disc lands first,
your opponent will drink
the combination
of the two beverages.
One, two, three, drop.
-Oh!
Me?
-Jimmy. No.
No, Paul, it is Paul.
Sorry, I was wrong.
-Wait. Who drinks? Paul?
-Who drinks?
-I drink?
You drink, Jimmy.
What is it? Gravy...
-Gravy and tequila.
-Gravy...and tequila.
-You're laughing.
-That's awful.
-They call it Thanksgiving
south of the border.
Paul.
-What?
-Your new movie is called
"Ant-Man"?
-It is. Yes.
-Why don't they
just call it uncle?
-No, not --
-Different ant, man.
-That's pretty good, Drinko.
-Thank you. I've got
Lyme disease. Be cool.
I'm just trying my best.
Alright, Jimmy.
Chug it.
♪♪
-It's all -- It's -- It's --
It's -- It's --
-[ Laughing ]
-Shut up!
Ugh. Oh, God.
-Delicious tequila gravy.
-This is the last time
we're playing Drinko,
ladies and gentlemen,
on our show.
Congratulations to Paul Rudd,
the winner.
I'm sorry. I don't know what
this is on my desk.
-What is that?
-It's my mustache.
Is it yours?
I don't know.
There was tape on my desk.
Here.
-What is it?
[ Laughter ]
It's just a piece of tape.
-Remember when like --
Was it --
Can you do that with that?
It's a very thin piece of tape.
-I don't think so.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's pretty good.
Yeah, that's pretty good.
Did you just sneeze?
Paul, do you need a tissue?
Paul, here.
-But, anyway, the Super Bowl,
it's gonna be a great --
It's gonna be a really --
-No, I know, it's gonna be
exciting, but --
[ Laughter ]
I'll get it.
-Wait.
-Yeah, do it, right.
Why don't you talk
about "Ant-Man"?
-[ Sneezes ]
-Oh, God bless you.
God bless you.
-Okay. So, anyway --
-No.
[ Laughter and applause ]
No, no, no, not that nose.
-The thing about "Ant-Man" is,
you know, it's a serious film.
-It is?
-And, I mean, this is --
it's different than the others.
-Look at the clip over there.
Maybe the clip is --
-The other "Ant-Man" films
are kind of like
small family films
and then this one
is like just --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This is, yeah.
Wow!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Paul, Paul.
-It's huge in scale.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's just absolutely huge
in scale.
-Did you want some --
Paul, Paul.
[ Laughter ]
Paul, here, here.
Absolutely, yeah.
-Thank you very much.
-Thank you for coming on.
I appreciate that.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you very much.
-You have a little
something over here. Yeah.
The other side.
Thank you, yeah.
-Did I get it?
-Yeah.
-I'll get it, yeah.
I'll get it.
There you go.
-Pfft!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Thank you.
I want to talk about this --
-People, by the way --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you for doing that.
-People --
Did it look real?
-Yeah, of course.
-Are people gonna like
flip on and think that's real?
-Yeah, of course.
-Great.
-That's fun.
[ Laughter ]
You always come on
and do a fun bit.
And then we'll get
to the real meat and potatoes
of the interview here.
It's "Ant-Man,"
"Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I saw it.
It is fantastic.
It is giant.
-Thank you, yeah.
-It's massive.
I mean, is it --
I don't know.
Is it tough to be involved
in a set that's all CGI?
-There were some days there was
the thing called volume.
And some days we would film
and people said,
[ Whispering ]
"You know, we're going to film
the volume."
And the volume is
a new technology.
You know, normally you're
shooting with bluescreens
all around you,
but it's this --
it's like an LED screen
that wraps
around an entire sound stage.
And so they try and make it feel
as much like the quantum realm
or whatever and we have
something to react to.
And it was crazy
to go into these sound stages
and it looked like you were
in outer space, something wild.
-And what is the ground like?
Is it the ground --
-They put on dirt.
They like have dirt
and they try and have as much
practical stuff as possible.
-So you really feel like you're
on a planet or whatever.
-You really feel like you're
on a planet
or you're in some weird space.
One of the things that --
Actually, we went in
and there was dirt all
over the floor
and we were shooting with like
150 other creatures and people
and it doesn't smell good
at all.
[ Laughter ]
"Mm."
And then throughout the day,
it was kind of getting worse
and worse.
The next day,
it was like overbearing
and we realized they probably
got a deal on the dirt
because it actually wasn't dirt.
It was manure.
[ Ohhs and laughter ]
-What?!
Are you kidding me?
-No.
-Wow!
-They actually had to kind of
shut it down for a day
and then bring in some new dirt.
I don't think anyone knew
and it was --
-You'd think manure would be
more expensive than dirt.
-Apparently not.
-Apparently not!
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah,
the quantum realm just reeks.
-Wow! I did not know that.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Paul, how do we set up
this film?
I would say it's just
action adventure comedy.
It's family-friendly.
-Yeah.
-A lot of family.
-It's a little bit like --
You know, family was,
I think, a theme in the other
"Ant-Man" movies, and comedy,
and I think some of that exists
in this one, too,
but it's
on a much grander scale.
It's starting off Phase 5
of Marvel, which --
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Which is very exciting,
introducing a new
big, bad villain called
Kang the Conqueror.
-Yeah.
-Which is,
if you look
at those pictures of Jonathan,
I think you could probably
buy him as a conqueror.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's Kang.
-He's fantastic.
-He really is.
-And so, yeah --
-Everyone's great.
-It just feels like a much --
-Michelle Pfeiffer is fantastic.
-She's always great.
-Evangeline Lilly.
-Great.
-Bill Murray.
-How about that?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Awesome.
-Come on.
And you! And you got you.
-And Michael Douglas.
-And Michael Douglas, too.
The whole cast is --
-And Kathryn Newton,
who was here.
-By the way, she hit a home run
in this movie.
She's phenomenal.
-How great is she?
-Everyone's gonna fall
in love with her.
-Yeah. She's awesome.
-It's really good that you get
sent into the quantum realm
through this thing
that your daughter invents.
It's like a beacon that she
shouldn't have sent out.
And then you -- I don't want
to explain what really --
-I think you just did.
-Yeah, I did.
[ Laughter ]
And then you got to --
-Marvel will be thrilled.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I want to show --
-They don't really care, though.
They're like,
"Tell whatever you want."
They don't mind. It's so weird.
Marvel doesn't care
what you say, yeah.
-They really love it, yeah.
Sorry, Marvel. It's really good.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Paul Rudd
in "Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheering ]
-"Do I miss the action?
Sometimes.
Will I be there
when the Avengers need me?
Absolutely.
I'd never turn my back on them.
But right now, the only job
I want is being a dad.
I love you, Cassie.
Thanks for being my hero.
And I'm sorry
I missed some birthdays.
[ Awws ]
And, for the rest of you kids
out there,
word of advice --
look out for the little guy."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're at a book signing.
-Yeah, yeah, I probably
should've said that,
shouldn't I? I guess, yeah.
Scott Lang wrote a book after,
to tell everybody
what's been going on with the,
you know,
the events of "Endgame"
and everything.
-The thing I like about you
and your character in this
is that you do play --
You're the first kind of,
in my mind, a funny superhero
dad type of character,
where you're just --
It's very --
Your scenes are so comedic
and funny
and your dynamic
with your daughter.
I don't want to, again, spoil,
but you crush it, buddy.
-Thank you, Jimmy, thank you.
-You crush it.
I want -- The movie's gonna
be huge all over the world
and I want to make sure
that everyone,
all audiences everywhere,
get to hear you talk about it.
So, if you don't mind,
I'm gonna do a new thing,
a new technology.
It's called live dubbing, okay?
-Yeah.
-And we've never done this,
right on the show.
I have this remote here, okay?
And it will switch languages
every time I hit a button.
-Wow. Oh, alright.
-So, you want to try it?
Here to talk about the new
movie "Ant-Man" is Paul Rudd.
Tell us about "Ant-Man."
-Alright. Well, sure.
You know,
in "Quantumania,"
I play Scott Lang, aka Ant-Man,
and, you know, my family are...
[ Laughter ]
-Straight bussin', no cap.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Ant-Man" is low-key GOATed
when seeing an exciting movie
is the vibe.
Thanks, fam!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "King of Wishful Thinking"
playing ]
♪♪
-♪ I don't need to fall
at your feet ♪
♪ Just 'cause you
cut me to the bone ♪
♪ And I won't miss the way
that you kiss me ♪
♪ We were never carved
in stone ♪
♪ If I don't listen to the talk
of the town ♪
♪ Then maybe I can fool myself ♪
-♪ I'll get over you,
I know I will ♪
♪ I'll pretend my ship's
not sinking ♪
♪ And I'll tell myself
I'm over you ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm the king
of wishful thinking ♪
-♪ King of wishful thinking ♪
-♪ Ooh, I am the king
of wishful thinking ♪
♪ I refuse to give in
to my blues ♪
-♪ That's not how
it's gonna be ♪
-♪ And I deny the tears
in my eyes ♪
♪ I don't wanna
let you see, no ♪
♪ That you have made a hole
in my heart ♪
♪ And now I've got
to fool myself ♪
-♪ I'll get over you,
I know I will ♪
♪ I'll pretend my ship's
not sinking ♪
♪ And I'll tell myself
I'm over you ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm the king
of wishful thinking ♪
-♪ King of wishful thinking ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, no, I will never,
never shed a tear for you ♪
♪ I'll get over you,
I know I will ♪
♪ But I won't shed a tear
for you ♪
♪ I'll be the king
of wishful thinking ♪
♪ I'll get over you,
I know I will ♪
♪ You made a hole in my heart ♪
♪ I'll tell myself
I'm over you ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm the king
of wishful thinking ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]